- Chaque jour, les enfants
arrivent à la maison très
heureuses, très curieuses,
très engagées dans leur
apprentissage de français.
OK, vous pouvez enlever
les manteaux.
ESTHER GERBRANDT, élève,
École élémentaire de Harvey
- J'aime le français.
Et "like", si j'ai... le choix,
je vais faire le français
pour comme toutes les années.
- Esther a 1s.s.s. Sa soeur
Madeleine en a 8. Elles sont
en immersion française
à l'École élémentaire de Harvey,
près rereredericton.
- "Bonjour, petit hippocampe",
dit Dauphin.
leleles peuvent déjà bien
lire et écrire en français.
Et les parents en sont fiers.
Ils veulent des enfants
bilingues.
Mais ils s'inquiètent
pour le petit, Jacob.
Il est en maternelle et
ne pourra peut-être jamais
faire l'immersion française
au Nouveau-Brunswick.
- I would say...
- Le premier ministre
Blaine Higgst t t commencer
à éliminer l'immersion pour
les élèves de la première année
dès septembre, au moment
où Jacob doit entreprendre
samièmièmière année.
JULIANNE GERBRANDT,
mère d'Esther
- Au début, c'était incroyable
parce que je n'ai pas voulule c!
- Incroyable pour
Julianne Gerbrandt, incroyable
aussi pour les parents assis
autour de cette table.
Ils sont du réseau Canadian
Parents for French, réunis
en comité des provinces
de l'Atlantique avec
la représentante nationale.
Ce sont des parents
anglophones qui militent pour
l'apprentissage du français,
au pays et ils tiennent
à l'immersion française.
- If this is happening
in New Brunswick. it could...
- "Si ça arrive
au Nouveau-Brunswick,
ça pourrait arriver
dans les autres provinces",
craint Nicole Thibault.
NICOLE THIBAULT, PDG, Canadian
Parents for French Network
- On est surpris parce qu'on
voit le Nouveau-Brunswick
toujours comme un leader,
surtout dans la matière
des langues officielles,
l'apprentissage, la recherche.
- De nombreuses recherches
démontrent que l'immersion
française forme les élèves
les plus bilingues.
- C'était le tour de qui?
- Alors, pourquoi le premier
ministre Blae e e Higgs
est-il pressé d'éliminer
l'immersion française?
"Notre but est d'avoir
plus d'enfants angononones
capables de s'exprimer
dans les deux langues,
explique-t-il, et non plus
seulement ceux de l'immersion,
qui représntntnt environ
le tiers de tous élèves."
- Ah! Oui!
- Quel programme pour tous
va donc remplacer l'immersion
française? Les familles
ne le savent toujours pas,
à 10 mois de la prochaine
rentrée scolaire.
(en anglais)
"Je suis très frustrée,
nous explique Natasha, parce que
je perds mon français."
Efrfrfréquente l'école
Maplehurst, à Moncton, où
on a implanté un projet pilote :
les élèves d'immersion
de 7e année, comme elle,se retrs
où les enseignants donnent
le cours à la fois en français
et en anglais. Ce n'est donc
plus de l'immersion.
"Si on parle de moins en moins
en français, on le p
ajoute-t-elle. C'est pour ça
que je vous parle en anglais."
- Oh! I'm very disappointed...
- Sa mère erèrèrès déçue
et se demande comment
Natasha va réussir à rattraper
le français qu'elle a déjà
perdu,tetete année.
Elle se demande aussi
ce qui attend tous les autres
élèves de la province, une fois
mememersion abolie partout.
"C'est irresponsabl
de vouloir remplacer
l'immersion aussi vite et
sans un plan solide", dit-elle.
- Qu'est-ce quususus avez fait
aujourd'hui?
- Six fois... six plus quatre.
- Julianne Gerbrandt
tient à l'immersion pour
ses trois enfants. Inquiète,
elle ne peut qu'espérer
que le nouveau programme de
septembre sera aussi efficace.
- Parce que sinon,
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a enlevé
cette opportunité à tellement
d'élèves? Parce que c'est
un programme très populair
dans notre province.
- Je pense que j'ai besoin
de fain n n autre numéro.
- Non... c'est bie